[Music]
foreign
[Music]
yeah man I can't really talk now
the new millennium
Global if horror movies reflect the
fears and concerns of a people it's
noticeable that America claimed torture
porn as their derriger sub-genre
something in Saw and it's ilk's slowed
roasted dismantling of human flesh
appealed to a nation consumed by post-9
11 paranoia and a bombardment of wartime
images and atrocity
oh
my God
but while these movies made a killing at
the box office none were ever
particularly well reviewed recovering
from the 90s Soul drums the best horror
movies came from overseas as digital
cameras lowered the cost to film and the
rise of the internet made knowledge and
dissemination of these movies as simple
as a mouse click in fact more than half
of the movies included here were shot
outside of the states
so with all of that it is time to add
some scary midis to your Myspace and set
your aim status to away forever because
we're counting down the best 2000 horror
movies
[Applause]
[Music]
number 10 28 Days Later a group of
misguided animal rights activists free a
caged chimp infected with the rage virus
from a medical research lab when London
bike Courier Jim wakes up from a coma a
month later he finds his City all but
deserted on the run from the zombie-like
victims of the rage Jim stumbles Upon A
group of survivors including Selena and
cab driver Frank and joins them on a
perilous journey to what he hopes will
be safety starring Killian Murphy Noah
Huntley Naomi Harris and directed by
Danny Boyle critics say kinetically
directed by Danny Boyle 28 Days Later is
both a terrifying zombie movie and a
sharp political allegory
ah
[Applause]
dad are you all right
yeah I'm fine sweetheart
sorry I lost my temper Hannah
I love you very much
what keep away from me
stay where you are
dad keep away from McDonald's
[Music]
[Applause]
number nine Zombieland
after a virus turns most people into
zombies the world surviving humans
remain locked in an ongoing battle
against the hungry Undead for survivors
Tallahassee and his cohorts Columbus
Wichita and Little Rock abide by a list
of survival rules and zombie killing
strategies as they make their way toward
a rumored Safe Haven in Los Angeles
starring Woody Harrelson Jesse Eisenberg
Emma Stone and directed by Reuben
fleisher critics say wickedly funny and
featuring plenty of Gore Zombieland is
proof that the zombie subgenre is far
from dead
oh [ __ ]
Wichita
oh my God
look at this [ __ ] clown
[Music]
of course
it had to be a clown
no it had to be a clown
and it had to be Wichita for me to
finally understand
that some rules are made to be broken
and to nut up or shut up
this clown
[Music]
[Applause]
number eight Ginger Snaps
the story of two Outcast sisters Ginger
and Brigitte in the Mindless Suburban
town of Bailey Downs on the night of
Ginger's first period She is savagely
attacked by a wild creature Ginger's
wounds miraculously heal but something
is not quite right now Brigitte must
save her sister and save herself
starring Emily Perkins Catherine
Isabelle Chris lemch and directed by
John Fawcett critics say the strong
female cast and biting satire of Teenage
life makes Ginger Snaps far more
memorable than your average werewolf
movie or teen flick
laughs
Ginger
oh
my God
number seven wreck
a reporter and her cameraman record the
horrifying outbreak of a disease that
turns humans into vicious cannibals
starring Manuela Velasco Faron terrazza
Jorge yamam Serrano and directed by Jean
balaguero and Paco Plaza critics say
plunging viewers into the nightmarish
hellscape of an apartment complex Under
Siege wreck proves that found footage
can still be used as an effective
delivery mechanism for sparse economic
horror
[Applause]
ah
again
foreign
foreign
number six Sean of the Dead
Sean is a 30-something loser with a dull
easy existence when he's not working at
the electronic store he lives with his
slovenly best friend Ed in a small flat
on the outskirts of London now the only
unpredictable element in his life is his
girlfriend Liz who wishes desperately
for Sean to grow up and be a man when
the town is inexplicably overrun with
zombies Sean must rise to the occasion
and protect both Liz and his mother
starring Simon Pegg Nick Frost Kate
Ashfield and directed by Edgar Wright
critics say Shaun of the Dead cleverly
balanced his scares and witty satire
making for a bloody good zombie movie
with loads of wit
now some of these are limited
um
[Music]
definitely not the Batman soundtrack
oh
stone roses uh no
second coming I like it
that's Liz's yeah but she did dump you
there's some good in a shed so he said
it was locked
foreign
number five Drag Me to Hell
Christine Brown has a loving boyfriend
and a great job at an LA bank but her
Heavenly life becomes hellish when in an
effort to impress her boss she denies an
old woman's request for an extension of
her home loan in retaliation the Crone
places a curse on Christine threatening
her soul with eternal damnation
Christine seeks a psychic's help to
break the curse but the price to see
were sold may be more than she can pay
starring Allison loham Justin Long Lorna
raver and directed by Sam Raimi critics
say Sam Raimi returns to top form with
Drag Me to Hell a frightening hilarious
delightfully campy Thrill Ride
inside the soul of Christian Brown we
will Feast upon it as she Fest us on the
brave
you're Jim jacks
surely you can be dissuaded from taking
this insignificant woman surely she's
not worthy of your greatness
[Laughter]
oh
I come for you Christine
you're mine
you black-hearted
Number Four The Devil's Backbone
after losing his father ten-year-old
Carlos arrives at the Santa Lucia school
which shelters Orphans of the Republican
militia and politicians and is taken in
by the Steely headmistress Carmen and
the kindly Professor casarez soon after
his arrival Carlos has a run-in with the
violent caretaker Jacinto gradually
Carlos uncovers the secrets of the
school including the youthful ghosts
that wanders the grounds starring
Marissa Paredes Eduardo Noriega Federico
Lupe and directed by Guillermo del Toro
critics say creepily atmospheric and
haunting the Devil's Backbone is both a
potent ghost story and an intelligent
political allegory
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
number three The Host
careless American military personnel
dumped chemicals into South Korea's Han
River several years later a creature
emerges from the tainted Waters and
sinks its ravenous Jaws into local
residents when a creature abducts their
daughter a vendor and his family decide
that they are the only ones who can save
her starring song Kang ho bianhi bong
parquel and directed by bang Jun ho
critics say as populous pleasing as it
is intellectually satisfying the host
combined scares laughs and satire into a
riveting monster movie
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
don't worry
[Music]
number two hands Labyrinth
in 1944 Spain young Ophelia and her
ailing mother arrive at the post of her
mother's new husband a sadistic Army
officer who's trying to quell a gorilla
Uprising while exploring an ancient maze
Ophelia encounters the Fawn pan who
tells her that she is a legendary lost
princess and must complete three
dangerous tasks in order to claim
immortality starring Ivana bakero Sergey
Lopez Maribel Verdu and directed by
Guillermo del Toro critics say Pan's
Labyrinth is Alice in Wonderland for
grown-ups with the horrors of both
reality and fantasy Blended together
into an extraordinary spellbinding fable
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
here are some honorable mentions
The Descent
a year after a severe emotional trauma
Sarah goes to North Carolina to spend
some time exploring caves with her
friends after descending underground the
women find strange cave paintings and
evidence of an earlier Expedition then
learned that they are not alone
underground Predators inhabit the
crevices and they have a taste for human
flesh starring Shauna McDonald Natalie
Mendoza Alex Reed and directed by Neil
Marshall critics say deaf Direction and
strong performances from its all-female
cast guide The Descent a riveting
claustrophobic horror film
dead animals
hundreds of them this is not good guys
can we get out of here which way
I don't know what do you mean you don't
know there's no grief it could be any
one of these tunnels take your pick
okay
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
slither
[Music]
wheel Z is a small town where not much
happens and everyone Minds his own
business no one notices when evil slips
in quietly but when people find
mutilated livestock and a woman goes
missing Sheriff Bill party discovers an
alien organism that threatens to devour
all life on earth starring Nathan
Fillion Elizabeth Banks Michael Rooker
and directed by James Gunn critics say a
slimy B movie homage oozing with
affection for low budget horror films
Slither is creepy and funny if you've
got the stomach for it
don't mess with me
[Music]
hey
what's going on
what the hell you doing
what the hell happened to you artist
poison ivy Outback maybe
no they're not my parents they're trying
to trick you
the worms are in their brain
all right look I y'all stay right there
on the spot I'm gonna call the
paramedics come help you and uh Kylie's
gonna come with me here come here
the orphanage
Laura has happy memories of her
childhood in an orphanage she convinces
her husband to buy the place and help
her convert it into a home for sick
children one day her own adopted son
Simon disappears Simon is critically ill
and when he is still missing several
months later he is presumed dead grief
Shirk and Laura believes she hears
Spirit who may or may not be trying to
help her find the boy starring Belen
hueva Fernando Cayo Geraldine Chaplin
and directed by Juan Antonio bayona
critics say deeply unnerving and
surprisingly poignant the orphanage is
an atmospheric beautifully crafted
haunted house horror film that earns
scares with a minimum of blood
foreign
[Music]
come on
and finally number one Let the Right One
In when Oscar a sensitive bully 12 year
old boy living with his mother in
Suburban Sweden meets his new neighbor
the mysterious and Moody Ellie they
strike up a friendship initially
reserved with each other Oscar and Ellie
slowly form a close Bond but it soon
becomes apparent that she has no
ordinary young girl eventually Ellie
shares her dark Macabre secret with
Oscar revealing her connection to a
string of bloody local murders starring
care heed Brandt Lena Lee Anderson pair
Ragnar and directed by Thomas alfredson
critics say Let the Right One In
reinvigorates The seemingly tired
vampire genre by effectively mixing
scares with intelligent storytelling
foreign
well just definitely
foreign
that about does it for us be sure to
stay tuned to the Rotten Tomatoes
channel for more of the entertainment
content you love until next time I'm
your host Naz Perez and we'll see you
back here for more top tens on the
Rotten Tomatoes countdown
[Music]
foreign
[Music]